we're taking calls at six one seven
eight three zero four seven five zero we
are very very close to Tuesday's
presidential elections but we will will
answer questions about anything that's
on your mind who's joining me next all
David this is David are you David or is
your name also David oh no I just I was
on the line for a while I wasn't sure if
that was an automated message
oh sorry now this is this is me you're
live what's your name uh Daniel Daniel
okay what's up Daniel what can we do for
you hi I'm from Canada just just added
information there well thank you
I'm kind of new to the alternative news
surfing and yes it started watching qit
a few uh uh years ago and then i heard
about dave rubin and then that's how I
found out about you okay um I guess I
have two questions um I know that there
was some kind of food between qit and
sam Harris and then Sam Harris and then
Abbie Barton I'm just curious to hear
your opinions about GOI T and some hairs
and Abby Martin like the three intently
yes or if you know anything but a few I
know nothing about it no I mean what so
four I guess I'll tell you what I know
and I don't think it's really much of a
secret
I I know Dave Rubin Dave Rubin is a
friend of mine and he we speak every
once in a while you know every few
months or something like that he left he
whitey at some point I don't even know I
guess it must have been about a year and
a half ago or two years ago at this
point I'm not even totally sure uh as
far as a feud goes I don't know much
about it and then the Abby Martin thing
I know nothing about that would there's
some feud between Abby and TYT oh not
true t uh her and Sam Harris I think oh
okay well yeah I mean I think maybe her
views don't align with his but to call
it a feud I don't know I wish I was more
informed about this I mean it sounds
fascinating I'll tell you but I just
know very little about maybe maybe I
shouldn't use it yeah so maybe maybe I
shouldn't use the bird feed I just know
that they were both on Joe Rogan and
they were Abby Abby Martin was on Joe
Rogan
and she was just basically you can find
all this on YouTube that's pretty much
where I watch everything
oh yes Abby Abby Martin was on t Rogan
and she was talking about I think
something about the Iraq war and they
had disagreement about the number of
deaths and the movies that issue thing
that um there was two million deaths in
the Middle East caused by the Iraq war
and I'm saddened Harris was saying that
number is ridiculous and that there was
only there's only two hundred thousand
in total were they on together this was
in separate interviews with Joe this is
separate all I see of everyone was on
first and shoes issues also talking
about centers during the first interview
and then centers came on after I got I
just really been yeah and um I know I'm
not super knowledgeable ER or I guess
educated so just recently we thought
about um them what do you think about
centers and IV learn okay so I mean I I
know Abby personally and she could not
be nicer politically we probably have
disagreements on the israeli-palestinian
conflict and I would guess maybe on some
other issues I don't really know I have
not really talked politics with her when
we hung out with just there was very
little political discussion that came up
Sam Harris
I don't know he says things that I agree
with and he says things that that I
don't agree with uh and III you know I'm
not a Sam Harris hater by any means I
know that there there may be are people
who want me to like slam sam Harris and
say that he's just objectively a
terrible person and blah blah blah
that's that's not what I think so so I
wouldn't say anything like that uh but
I'll check out the interviews you're
talking about I haven't seen any of them
and it sounds interesting if nothing
else okay
yeah uh sorry I am I talking too much or
is there like a time time frame for free
scholarship they were five seconds from
the time limits so I'm gonna thank you
for the call and move on but I really
appreciate it I think you talked the
exact right amount you were clear you
were precise and I really appreciate
your questions thank you